yo what's up guys it's marcus brownlee
here from mkbhd and welcome to another
hd video this one is going to be tech
channel of the week number three
gigafied and this is gigafives youtube
channel i'm gonna maximize this here uh
so yes their channel right now is in the
beta layout but i'm just gonna show you
their uh their channel right now i'm
just gonna give you a quick tour of
their channel because this is the tech
channel of the week
um now first of all they do have a ton
of uploads and i can't exactly find
exactly how many uploads there are but
as you can see there are a ton and he
does a lot of tech videos a lot of
software videos and a lot of them are
software although his most recent one
was a uh a bunch of free alternatives to
the actual software uh so if you wanted
to instead of getting microsoft word you
can use google docs stuff stuff like
that
so yeah he does have some awesome
quality videos i'm a subscriber of him
he's a subscriber of me
and uh right now he has 15 600
subscribers so i'm sure he doesn't need
a shout out but uh this is his channel
as of today uh so basically what he's
doing um also he does have a website
tinkernet.com
and basically what he's doing is showing
he's just giving everybody a ton of
knowledge he has
a ton of uh of hardware and software
videos and uh from what i know this is
this channel is run by one person um
most of the reviews have thousands of
views but uh some of them are hacking
videos some of them are installation
videos uh some of them are you know just
just cool tricks that you can find so
again the free alternative to paid
software video was one of his most
recent ones he also does have a few
playlists that i've checked out so you
really might want to check out this
channel
and just get a look of how many awesome
videos are on this channel and maybe you
want to maybe want to check some of
these out
so yeah gigafy is tech channel of the
week number three i hope you um
maybe you want to go check out this
channel again this is um this tech
channel the week series is basically a a
subscriber of me who does produce um
high quality tech related videos and um
every time someone subscribes i do go
over and visit their channel leave a
comment saying thanks and oftentimes
i'll subscribe to them seeing that they
have a good channel uh so yeah thanks
for watching this tech channel of the
week number three hope it was helpful
maybe you want to go check them out
their link or his link is in the
description and that is basically it
thanks for watching guys peace